[music playing]
NARRATOR: I'm losing daylight.
This is an expanse
of grassland and it
has what I need for a shelter.
And all this grass that
I'm going to cut down,
I'm going to either turn into
my bed or use for my roof.
Hits the rainy
season which means,
you better count on it raining.
No.
Wait.
Oh, my gosh.
I cannot believe this.
While I was chopping I
chopped up a clump of grass
and under the dirt clod, I just
saw this little bit of color.
I would have never
thought in my entire life
I would see one of
these in real life.
This is a blind worm snake.
It has a little
flickering tongue
as it's a digging machine.
It uses this its nose which
is one big large hard scale.
And it uses it like
a shovel or a wedge
and it's able to dig through the
ground and look for its prey.
NARRATOR: It's a
seven-striped blind snake,
a truly bizarre species.
It spends its life
deep underground.
So sightings are
incredibly rare.
When you're out here, you're
up to your knees in mud.
You have funguses
and parasites and all
the wounds that get infected.
The rain.
If you don't love these little
things like this along the way,
this place would destroy you.
NARRATOR: Here just a few
100 miles from the equator,
the light goes
out like a switch.
I've got to get
back to my shelter.
[music playing]